okay so I had a thought
and I was thinking about how I would
always see
conservative or like self-improvement
like influencers
you know talk about how men don't make
enough money for women
you know how is she supposed to submit
to you if she make 45 55 65 000 a year
and basically calling those guys losers
and I really got to thinking about this
and I'm like okay let me get this
straight
the man
the man that talk into microphones
for work
they speak into microphones
or a lot of them made their money
through like crypto or Bitcoin or like
whatever it is and I was just thinking
like the audacity you guys couldn't even
do what you do
without the average man that runs
Society average earners so 45
5 60
000 35
000 the janitors
um the truckers
um
the police officers the firemen a lot of
these guys are an average salaries
and you literally couldn't function
without and I don't really like it I
don't really like
[__] on average men
and saying they don't make enough money
for women who as a group were all below
average like by every number in all of
history were fatter
we have less kids we're more promiscuous
as a group and saying well how is this
you know from a historical point of view
below average woman
going to submit
to an average man
when
yeah and I just
I just think it's crazy how they'll call
these guys losers when 45 of men have an
infrastructure job and just you know
when I did that definition I expanded it
a little bit
adding in truckers adding in transport
um adding in construction workers
firemen police officers Army Etc
but half of men literally
allow us to live
this amazing life
that we live today and as a thank you
all of these guys will say the men are
the problem
they're not making enough money crazy
craziness you know what percent of women
do infrastructure jobs seven
percent and let's be honest I think it's
like one or two percent are firemen and
police officers
they're just there as like a
participation trophy so my two cents
morning coffee I'm in Atlanta I might
interview some people out here see what
the dating scene is like
see what people love to say about it but
let me know
like the video guys
subscribe I'll talk to you next time